the storm in hawaii falls on the 80th
anniversary of the attack on pearl
harbor japanese planes carry out a
surprise strike on u.s military bases on
oahu more than 2 400 americans were
killed propelling the country into world
war ii now some of the few remaining
survivors are in hawaii paying homage to
the victims john dickerson is there john
good morning
good morning from a very rainy pearl
harbor we're hours away from the start
of ceremonies here
at this time 80 years ago sailors from
the pacific fleet were still asleep in
their bunks many of them had attended a
band concert the night before
miles away out in the pacific japanese
submarines and aircraft carriers cut
through the waters
undetected behind me is the memorial to
the uss arizona and shortly before 8 a.m
members of its crew saw the skies
blackened with japanese warplanes some
of them flying no more than 40 feet
above the ground
the sailors did the best that they could
one man rushed to his station in his
pajamas they shot me up but they didn't
shoot me down
others smashed open the ready boxes to
free ammunition and everywhere sailors
craned their necks looking for the
source a seemingly unending stream of
planes bombs and machine gun fire when
the attack started mickey ganache scaled
60 feet to the crow's nest of the uss
pennsylvania to spot incoming planes
that's where i was right up in the
battle battle station
the craziness
about 70 60 70 feet up in the air
one of the bombs carved through the
arizona hitting the gunpowder magazine
stored below
in the explosion the hull of the 31 000
ton vessel rose out of the water
splitting and sinking to the bottom
where more than 900 sailors are
permanently buried oil from the ship is
still leaking giving the water at the
memorial a technicolor sheen
those who have served on the arizona and
survived the attack can have their ashes
interred there 44 have done so in all 21
ships were either sunk or gravely
damaged some listing so badly that they
sat sideways in the water i went top
side
by time i get top side the ship was
almost ready to compensate more than 300
planes were destroyed
more than 2 400 united states military
and civilians were killed
[Music]
around 30 survivors will return today
many of them in their hundreds
recalling the faces of mates who live in
their memory as 19 forever i survived so
i can tell about it
a lot of people cannot and i fear i'm
honoring them by
being there and showing my face and
spreading the knowledge that i have
gained there to other people that i talk
to
this is likely to be the last major
anniversary of their lifetimes people
walk down the street here and they say
thank you for service and my comment is
there
you were worth serving for
[Music]
last year the pandemic kept world war ii
veterans and survivors of the attack on
pearl harbor from coming here to
commemorate the anniversary
according to the department of veterans
affairs of the 16 million who served in
world war ii
roughly 240 000 are still living
thank you john dickerson that was a very
powerful statement we heard in your
piece thank you for your service and the
response you were worth serving for i
won't forget that